now i could not be more excited than i
am for today's show because it has a
theme
um a very strong theme actually
uh it's literally been 22 years in the
making back in 1999 i was lucky enough
to be in it
and it's just really near and dear to my
heart it's uh it's never been kissed
and today
i am actually
reuniting with some of the cats
because also who doesn't love
a reunion but first in honor of never
been kissed we have a viewer who wrote
in looking for help in the love
department and tasha says that she has
never been kissed
by her new
boyfriend
so she's gonna join us now from the
california state baseball field
tasha
hello
hey drew
so yes my boyfriend hunter and i we
started dating over the summer during
the pandemic uh-huh and we that
we actually met five years ago and
essentially we were dating other people
so we just became really good friends
over the years and about three months
ago we decided to take our relationship
to the next level
and now we are official
so um now
it's just a matter of us having this
first kiss which we have not had yet
well let me just ask a question that
comes to my mind why has there been no
kiss so far
[Laughter]
honestly i feel like we just have a
classic case of ross and rachel syndrome
where we've been friends for so long and
now there's just this
big build up and we're both so nervous
and excited and we want it to be perfect
and i sent hunter a text this morning
uh inviting him here and i said you know
i don't want a response
just trust me and show up if you are
ready to take this to the next level and
make it the real deal
so i'm here at the pitchers mound
at cal state i have no idea if he's
going to show up or not but
you only live once right
i love this this moment is special and
we're all invested in it with you we're
gonna check in with you
and uh let's see if we can create a
happy ending
for today
at the beginning of the show we met
tasha who has asked for help in the
romance department three months ago
tasha's best friend
hunter
became her boyfriend and yet she's never
been kissed by him how perfect is that
for our never been kissed reunion
now
tasha has asked hunter to meet her on
the pitcher's mound at california state
university if he's ready to make this
thing real here's hoping let's check in
and see if he's arrived
i'm nervous i'm so invested in this
tasha how are you feeling pretty nervous
um lots of butterflies
um i have no idea if he's gonna show up
i have a feeling he will
um this is a fantasy and yet it's your
reality and we're here to support you
and um wait i'm just getting word
hunter is there
hi guys we were we were in the middle of
something
um
i'm so happy for you both
you know there's um
there's an old saying that some of the
best relationships come out of
friendship
this is true
hunter how you feel
pretty good
it was uh it's a long time coming yeah
and tasha
how do you feel
very happy
you're grateful
congratulations on uh showing that
fantasies can become reality
uh thank you for letting us all be a
part of this moment we wish you the very
best
thanks for watching everyone
join us tomorrow for another sunny day
in l.a
as we bid you
good night
[Music]